resuelve la proporción 8 entre 36 es
igual a 10 entre cuanto o bien 8 a 36 es
igual a 10 a cuánto hay varias formas de
resolver este problema vamos a ver
cuatro de ellas la que te guste más esa
la puedes utilizar para resolver este
tipo de problemas entonces la primera
dice lo siguiente vamos a fijarnos en
cuanto se tuvo que multiplicar el
numerador para pasar de ser 8 a ser 10
como son fracciones equivalentes el
denominador también se tuvo que haber
multiplicado por eso mismo bueno si
empezamos con 8 y llegamos a 10
pudimos haber multiplicado por 10 entre
8 verdad lo voy a poner por acá si
hacemos 8 por 10 entre 8 definitivamente
llegamos a 10 entonces estamos
multiplicando por 10 entre 8 pero 10
entre 8 es exactamente lo mismo que 5
entre 4 simplemente simplificamos 10
entre 12 58 entre dos es cuatro entonces
estamos multiplicando el numerador por
cinco cuartos
así para obtener una expresión
equivalente el denominador también lo
tenemos que multiplicar por cinco
cuartos y eso nos da una forma de
encontrar el valor de n n es igual a 36
multiplicado por cinco por cinco cuartos
y aquí podemos efectuar las operaciones
esto de aquí es igual a 36 por 5
dividido entre 4 36 entre 4 es 9 y 9 por
5 es 45 así que esta es una forma de
obtener que el valor de n es igual a 45
una segunda forma es la siguiente ahora
podemos fijarnos en cuanto se tuvo que
multiplicar este numerador para llegar a
este denominador y ahí tendría que
multiplicarse por 36 entre 8 por 36
entre entre 8 y notemos que 36 entre 8
es lo mismo que vamos a simplificar lo
dividiendo el numerador y el denominador
entre 4 36 entre 4 es 9 y 8 entre 4 es 2
es el numerador se multiplicó por 9
medios por 9 medios para llegar al
denominador así que aquí también debemos
de multiplicar el numerador por 9 medios
para realmente tener una fracción
equivalente sale entonces deja lo como
por acá en algún lado multiplique 88 por
nueve medios nueve medios para llegar a
36 así que ahora debo multiplicar diez
diez por nueve medios por nueve medios
para llegar a n bueno aquí nos quedaría
diez por nueve dividido entre dos entre
2 10 entre 2 es 5 y 5 por 9 es 45 así
que esa es otra forma de obtener que n
es igual a 45 muy bien otra forma de
resolver este problema es multiplicar
cruzado ahorita te digo que quiere decir
multiplicar cruzado primero déjame
decirte que a mí no me gusta mucho
porque es una cosa muy algorítmica es
es un procedimiento que a veces no
explican por qué funcionan pero bueno
vamos a ver en qué consiste en
multiplicar cruzado es lo siguiente si
tenemos dos fracciones iguales déjame
poner aquí las fracciones otra vez voy a
ponerle 8 entre 36
8 / 36 es igual a 10 entre n 10 entre n
ok entonces si tenemos dos fracciones
iguales podemos multiplicar este
numerador por este en el denominador y
eso va a ser igual a este numerador por
este denominador lo voy a hacer con
colores este numerador por este
denominador o sea 8 n es igual a este
numerador por este denominador osea a 36
por 10 déjame realizar aquí algunas
operaciones entonces tenemos que 8 n es
igual a 36 por 10 o sea 360 sale esto
parece un poco como magia pero en
realidad está justificado en algo de
álgebra que ahorita vamos a ver entonces
vamos a seguir con este procedimiento
imagínate que ya sabemos que 8 n es
igual a 360 entonces cuál tendría que
ser el valor de n por cuánto tenemos que
multiplicar 8 para llegar a 360
bueno pues podemos dividir a ambos lados
de esta igualdad entre 8
es una igualdad que tenemos que hacer lo
mismo a ambos lados para que se
preserven la igualdad entonces aquí
divido entre 8 aquí también tengo que
dividir entre 8 8 n entre 8 me queda
simplemente n y de esta forma n es igual
a 360 entre 8 este argumento es un poco
algebraico pero pudimos haberlo hecho de
otra forma nosotros queríamos encontrar
8 por cuánto era igual a 360
bueno pues definitivamente 8 por 360
entre 8 es igual a 360 verdad entonces
este numerito n debe ser 360 entre 8
vamos a ver eso cuánto es realizando la
división de casitas entonces lo voy a
hacer por aquí 360 dividido entre 88
caben 36 4 veces 4 por 8 es 32 aquí
restamos 36 menos 32 64 baja el 0 5 por
8 es exactamente 40 aquí
55 x 8 es 40 restamos y no queda
residuos entonces una vez más nos queda
que el valor de n es igual a 45 y vamos
a la última forma de resolverlo la
última forma utiliza un poco de álgebra
así que algo a lo mejor los argumentos
te parezcan un poco extraños porque
estamos en la lista de reproducción de
proporciones pero bueno es padre que te
lo cuente porque así vas a poder
entender un poco mejor de donde sale
esto de la multiplicación cruzada
de eso multiplicar cruzado bueno si no
entiendes o se te hace un poco extraño
no te preocupes cuando aprendas un poco
más de álgebra le vas a entender mejor
pero vamos a hacerlo entonces la
proporción que tenemos es 8 entre 30 y
68 entre 36 es igual a 10 entre n lo que
vamos a hacer aquí es despejar n y para
despejar n conviene que quede en el
numerador así que voy a empezar
multiplicando por n
a ambos lados de esta igualdad sin
multiplicó por n de un lado debo
multiplicar por n del otro para que se
preserven la igualdad aquí está n se
cancela con esta n y me queda que 8
entre 36 x n 8 entre 36 x n es igual a
10 igual a 10 y ahora debo despejar n
así que debo deshacerme de este término
y para eso voy a multiplicar por 36
entre 8 si multiplicó por 36 entre 8 del
lado izquierdo también debo de
multiplicar por 36 entre 8 del lado
derecho para preservar la igualdad aquí
a la izquierda 36 se cancela con 36 8
con 8 y me queda simplemente que n n es
igual a 10 por 36 entre 8 o sea a 36 por
10 dividido entre 8 y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que obtuvimos aquí
a la izquierda simplemente 36 x 10 6 360
entonces n es igual a 360 dividido entre
8 y esto ayuda a entender mucho mejor de
dónde viene la multiplicación cruzada la
n la pasamos multiplicando pero eso
realmente es multiplicar por n de ambos
lados y el 36 también lo pasamos
multiplicando pero eso fue lo que
hicimos aquí cuando multiplicamos por 36
en el numerador de este lado y de este
lado y luego el 8 aquí lo pasamos
dividiendo dividimos entre 8 de ambos
lados que fue este entre 8 que quedó
aquí aquí entre 8 y aquí entre 8 bueno
entonces n también nos queda 360 entre 8
de modo que n una vez más es igual a 45
bueno aquí tienes cuatro formas de
resolver un mismo problema siempre nos
quedó que el valor de n es igual a 45 y
bueno depende de cuál prefieras
o cuál se te haga más sencilla para que
utilice esa en tus problemas creo que
las más sencillas son ver en cuánto
cambio el numerador y utilizar la
técnica de multiplicación
cruzada